that feeds exploitation and human
trafficking so today I applaud China for
stepping out assuming I applaud Canada
and tell what I'm thinking
no Joe we cannot tell what you're
thinking that's part of the problem I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report and
we are live on location here in
Washington D.C it is day three of our
three-day Bonanza tour of the nation's
capital of course guys as you know we
are live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals share subscribe tap that
notification Bell uh Bell if you have
not and it really has been quite a trip
here uh Ted Cruz Senator Ted Cruz is
going to be joining me for the live show
I'm not doing an interview with them we
are going to do a normal show clips
what's going on in DC what's been
happening in the news and obviously some
of the news last couple days has been uh
quite difficult with the situation in
Tennessee in the shooting there but
we're going to go through what's been
happening in the news and some of Ted
Cruz's greatest viral hits uh he was
supposed to be here two minutes ago he
is just finishing up a vote on the cat
at the Capitol which is just a few
minutes away from where we are so he
should be here any moment he might just
walk through the camera we're just going
to try to get him seated as quickly as
possible once he gets here but let me
just recap you guys on a little bit of
what we've been doing on this trip we
have been interviewing everybody and
anyone and everyone that we could get a
hold of here and we got some great names
for you I just want to write down a
couple things here real quick let me
tell you a little bit about what we've
done here so yesterday
was really the the main purpose of the
trip I did a live interview at the
Capitol in the Rayburn room with speaker
McCarthy we did an hour-long interview
we had a hundred members of our locals
Community came it was great seeing you
guys we did a little hangout last night
got to drink some tequila with the fine
folks in the community uh and uh and
share some uh good words and all that
good stuff so that was nice but we did
about an hour interview with Senator
McCarthy and then we took the audience
the hundred people we broke them down
into smaller groups gave everybody tours
of the capital it was really great and
as uh Kevin McCarthy pointed out and
when we post the interview you'll get to
see the people's house is now open again
there's no more covid nonsense there's
no more lockdown nonsense they're
letting the people back in and they're
they're actually and it was very
refreshing to see is some excitement in
this town again there is a feeling like
oh uh maybe the people's business can
actually be done I thought the the chat
with him was quite good I think you will
dig it and just to let you know what
else we've been doing here I mean I am
I'm telling you I've sat down with
anyone and everyone since we've been
here we had JD Vance this morning uh
obviously senator from Ohio we had
Congressman Byron Donalds alongside
Congressman Jim Jordan they were here
together this morning as I said we had
Kevin McCarthy yesterday we had Lauren
bobert from Colorado yesterday later
this afternoon we have Thomas Massey and
Chip Roy they'll be joining together we
had Marjorie Taylor green we had Matt
Gates we had Dan Crenshaw we had Senator
Ron Johnson two others that we were
supposed to do that unfortunately had to
be canceled Senator Marsha Blackburn
from Tennessee was supposed to be here
but obviously in light of the shooting
she wasn't able to do it and then
Senator Rand Paul I don't know if you
heard about this but one of his staffers
was stabbed repeatedly the other day
here in DC so he unfortunately had to
cancel as well it sounds like it was
completely random that it actually was
not having anything to do with the
senator or anything like that so that
that I guess is sort of nice to hear but
uh but in any event we couldn't get the
two of them but but really a ton of
interviews and and the Really the
driving theme has been something that
I've been talking about for a couple
months now which is that the Republicans
starting to dare I say stand up straight
with their shoulders back they're trying
to message this stuff properly show that
they can be the party of Competency and
it does seem to be working and that that
Florida blueprint that I'm always
talking about does seem to be making its
way even here to the swamp so there's
definitely some excitement here I've
thoroughly enjoyed it's really been like
nice to be here believe it or not I
don't leave the uh the free state of
Florida that often but it's been nice to
be here oh and speaking of the Free
State of Florida I did forget one
congresswoman Maria Salazar who is my
congresswoman from the Miami area in
Florida we've never met before we just
did the interview about 45 minutes ago
she is a absolute like ball of energy
and total Joy it was really great to
connect with her so you know what we're
going to do since uh just in case the
senator gets hung up a little bit let me
go into the first story and then we're
going to do everything else with him uh
and and to Ted Cruz's credit this
doesn't surprise me uh but he you know I
basically we said to him hey do you need
the rundown of the show because we're
going to go through a bunch of stuff
some of it involves you but some of it's
just the news of the day and he was like
don't worry about it like I'll get there
you'll play some clips we'll make it
happen uh so why don't we start with
this one and hopefully he'll just join
us while while we're in the middle of
this one actually uh yesterday there's
been a whole bunch of hearings here the
reason we came this week is because
Congress is in session right now there
are votes happening right now one vote
that happened that is the results uh
were good but the process is kind of
ridiculous is this parental rights Bill
uh which we talked about a couple days
ago basically every Republican except
for five voted for it every Democrat
every single Democrat voted against it
it was for transparency and education
right will you know what your kids are
learning will teachers be allowed to
talk to them about sex and gender behind
their back it was sort of a uh an
offshoot of Florida's HB 1557 Otherwise
Known unfortunately as though today Gay
uh anyway it did actually pass even
though no Democrats voted for it and
five Republicans as I said didn't vote
for it as well but really think about it
this is what we're up against right now
the idea that you will know what your
kids are learning at school that you
will be able to review the information
and the books that they will be reading
and things of that nature that is
something that every single Democrat
voted against
and then the wizard known as AOC
literally called it fascist she called
the bill fascist and it's being passed
by fascists and Hakeem Jeffries who's
the House minority leader a Democrat
said that that Republicans don't want
people to know about the Holocaust like
it's such a level of nonsense and one of
the things that I've
been discussing with all about dozen or
so maybe 15 people that I've chatted
with since we've been here has been that
very notion that what do you do when one
side is so disconnected from reality and
one of the interesting things that I've
been learning is a lot of them are
saying you know if you get these people
on the DL
they're a little more sane but they're
always playing to the media they're
playing to the radical base
and what do we do with that that really
is the question anyway Let's uh let's
start with a clip of Ted Cruz this is
Ted Cruz yesterday talking to Department
of Homeland and security secretary
Alejandro mayorcas over child sex
trafficking on the border and this is
something else what are these wristbands
I don't know what they are you don't
know what they are
Mr secretary you've just testified to
the American people you're incompetent
at your job because I've been to the
southern border and if you go to the
southern border along the southern
border you see thousands of these
wristbands because the illegal
immigrants wear them the drug cartels
every color corresponds to how many
thousands of dollars they owe the
cartels you've turned these cartels into
multi-billion dollar criminal
organizations and these are modern day
leg irons because these are children
being sold into sex slavery and you
don't even know what they are that is
astonishing Mr secretary how many
children have been sold into sex slavery
under your Administration Senator we are
taking it to the cartel how many
children have been sold into sex slavery
do you know how many children have been
sold into sex slavery to an
unprecedented degree Mr secretary I want
to say to you right now it is your
behavior is disgraceful and the deaths
the children assaulted the children
raped they are at your feet and if you
had Integrity you would resign
wow uh you don't see Ted Cruz fired up
like that too often I mean Cruz is known
for his measured responses he's Harvard
trained lawyer right I mean the guy
learned uh was a student of Alan
dershowitz over at Harvard Law I mean
he's known for measured takes explaining
things clearly I don't know that I've
ever seen him that fired up I mean
basically what's going on at the border
right now is that between the cartels
and our inept border security well I
don't know inept are they inept or are
they intentionally uh sabotaging border
security you can make a call on that one
I think the senator is going to be
walking in just a moment
um they there is a business there is a
business now of child sex trafficking
there is a business of allowing illegals
into this country and we have a a
Department of Homeland Security that is
doing absolutely nothing about it and I
see Ted Cruz is here he's going to walk
right past the camera are you ready for
this people he's getting he's getting
hooked up uh and I'll have him comment
on that because I've never seen him that
fired up and uh we'll see if we can keep
that energy going but mayorcas really
had nothing to say he had absolutely
nothing to say the end there uh where
the senator basically said you know you
should resign that's how bad this
situation is
um I don't know that it could be much
worse all right the senator is on his
way and Senator you're gonna walk right
through the camera we are a professional
operation here it's good to see you sir
we'll just have you put in the earpiece
so you're able to hear the other Clips
uh in just a moment so you can just
stick that there you know how to do that
right oh yeah you're an old Pro so the
clip that we just we just started we
showed the the clip from was that
yesterday with the the battle with
mayorkas yes yesterday one of the guys
come on and take care of that for you
yeah
this is called live television
I sir have never seen you that fired up
I mean has that was that have you ever
been doing one of these hearings and and
had sort of that kind of emotion I mean
that's that's not what you're known for
look I mean I was pissed off
um I was pissed off
a because I've seen too much of this I
mean I spend a lot of time on our
Southern border
I've seen too many of these children
who've been sexually abused and
brutalized I've seen the dead bodies on
our Southern border
and majorcus has such utter contempt
that it was infuriating he refused to
answer even a single question the entire
hearing I mean you could ask him what
day it was and he wouldn't give you a
straight answer he was just he had his
talking points that's what he was going
to say
and you know his his crocodile tears his
empty expressions of empathy I I feel
for
the people who are dying of overdoses no
you don't if if you feel for them you
would stop doing what's causing it he's
the one who's opened up the Border
and the sad reality is the man doesn't
give a damn that a hundred thousand
people died of an overdose last year
because if he did he wouldn't preside
over a wide open border that is turning
the drug cartels into multi-billionaires
so many of the interviews and I've done
about 12 interviews with Congress people
and Senators since I've been here so
many one of the things that it seems to
boil down to are intentions do you
believe they are doing this
intentionally or is this complete
ineptitude on his behalf the
administration Biden Etc to 100
intention
um I I wish they were more incompetent
the problem is they are exceptionally
incompetent at dismantling the Border
what what the Biden White House has done
it's weird on every issue
they have handed the agenda over to the
radical left so on immigration
it is the open border zealots who set
their immigration policy
um on gender policy it is the
transgender extreme that sets their
their policy on
on Law and Order it is the abolish the
police crowd and the George Soros
prosecutors that set their agenda
and it's bizarre because the positions
they're embracing are are supported by a
tiny fraction of Americans I mean 10 15
percent of Americans support these
policies
I don't know why they've decided to hand
their agenda over to the radical left
but if you look at what mallorcus has
done and what Biden has done
this crisis was caused
starting the day Biden became president
he did three decisions that caused it
number one he immediately halted
construction of the border wall number
two he reinstated Catch and Release and
number three he pulled out of the
incredibly successful remain in Mexico
agreement that caused this crisis
majorcus views his job not as stopping
illegal immigration
he views his job as making illegal
immigration faster and more efficient
he's trying to have even more illegal
immigrants get in here more quickly that
it is not only it's not incompetence it
is ideologically
he wants every illegal immigrant
possible brought into the U.S and Dave
the amazing thing is look
a couple of observations and I talk a
lot about it as you know I do a podcast
three times a week verdict with Ted Cruz
that's how we knew we didn't need to
give you the rundown today because I was
like I think the guy can handle it and
actually look my pod today is entirely
on the majorca's hearing so I mean I do
a deep dive on this hearing on today's
podcast verdict you should download it
um and you're a professional PR guy now
too lucky you got to do that the only
thing I can't do is I can't read ads
online the Senate ethics rules won't let
me do it so so Ben Ferguson gets to do
all the ads online and I get to sit
there and smile yeah there you go but
look what is interesting about there are
a lot of things that were interesting
about that hearing but one of the things
that was most interesting is mayorkas
when he was getting lit up and he was
clearly in trouble
he turns to Dick Durbin the Democrat
chairman of the Judiciary Committee and
he seeks helps he says hey will you help
me out now look I've served for 11 years
with Durbin on Judiciary Durbin as smart
as hell he likes to fight he and I have
battled a thousand times
um he comes after me I come after him as
chairman he loves to jump in when a
Democrat witness is getting beat up and
try to protect him and this is the first
time I've ever seen it Durbin looked at
him he's like wow it didn't say a word
and I think what's happening is Durbin
and the Senate Dems realize okay this
border is a disaster and I think they
want nothing to do with it I I what is
fascinating is I looked at yesterday
as a sign that the Democrats are ready
to throw mayorkas overboard
they're ready to see him get fired and
then just scapegoat him oh it was all
majorcas he's incompetent he's terrible
but the talking points the Senate
Democrats had
you know none of them were actually
engaging the substance of what we were
saying instead they were like well this
has been a problem long before Biden
well no yeah
2020 the last year the Trump presidency
we had the lowest rate of illegal
immigration in 45 years what we were
doing was working
Biden and Kamala Harris and mayorcus
deliberately Unwound that so let's show
one more clip from the hearing yesterday
uh you were not thrilled with his sort
of stammering answers uh here we go has
the crisis at our Southern border
made Americans less safe yes or no
Senator we are dedicated to the safety
has the crisis made Americans less safe
I don't I don't want a discourse it's a
yes or no question
Senator we have a challenge you refuse
to answer the questions not SEC Mr
secretary let me show you how someone
doing his job answers a question in a
straightforward manner Chief Ortiz
is the crisis that is currently ongoing
at the southern border making the Border
less safe for Americans and Aliens alike
answer yes one word one syllable three
letters that's how someone answers a
question and does their job you're being
a politician misleading the American
people let me give you a chance again
will you show the same Integrity Chief
Ortiz shows is the crisis at the
southern border making Americans less
safe yes or no Senator we have 260
thousand he refused to answer the
question let's move on
what's incredible about this you sort of
referenced it you know Biden put up a
tweet the other day and obviously he
doesn't tweet and they don't let him
hold the phone talking about the
fentanyl crisis
related to the border so on one hand
they're acknowledging it's a crisis
because they're saying we have a
fentanyl crisis we know where the
fentanyl is coming from but the guy he's
almost the perfect Democrat in an odd
way right because he can sit there
without falling out of his chair and he
doesn't say anything so it's like oh
look he's do you remember back in the
Iraq War you remember Baghdad Bob oh
yeah uh Saddam Hussein's press secretary
that would get up and just see things
are going great that's mayorcas yep
everything is awesome we're doing boy
aren't we doing a good job I mean that's
it is I don't think I've ever seen a
witness who so consistently refuses to
answer every single question
and
I guess his handlers have told him
whatever they ask just repeat your
talking points and that's what he does
but it it shows contempt look it's not
just contempt for congress he certainly
is content for Congress
but it's ultimately it's contempt for
the American people because the reason
you have an oversight hearing under a
Constitution under article one Congress
has an oversight responsibility for the
executive and when I'm asking questions
what I'm trying to do I'm not just
asking the questions that pop into my
head that seem interesting
I've got a job which is to represent 30
million Texans the questions I'm asking
mayor so the questions I'm hearing from
Texans you know Texans don't have to
struggle with is this a crisis because
they're seeing the misery they're seeing
the suffering they're seeing the dead
bodies they're saying the crime they're
seeing the drugs they're seeing the
women who are sexually assaulted
you know I'll tell you something that
when I was last down at the border I
brought a group of senators to go go see
firsthand what was happening I've done
that a lot we go out on midnight Patrol
with the border patrol one of the times
there we encountered a dead body
floating in the Rio Grande river of
someone who drowned
um
the last time I was there the border
patrol agents told me about a new
phenomenon and I apologize this is
graphic
but it's something they call rape trees
and the traffickers are bringing women
across the border and in the United
States they will violently rape these
women
and then they will take their underwear
and hang them in the tree
and border patrol agents will find trees
in Texas find trees in Arizona
with 10 15 20 pairs of women's underwear
as as just trophies but also taunting
law enforcement you can't do a damn
thing about it we can do whatever we
want that is Joe Biden's fault that is
mayorcas's fault you want to know why I
was pissed because when I'm thinking of
the atrocities that are happening
and as far as majorcus is concerned
those can keep happening and they can
escalate I have to say I think your
prediction is probably right if they
need a sacrificial lamb here which they
probably do before 2024 so that Biden
can appear tough on the border mayorcus
is probably out let's shift because
obviously the big thing over the last
few days was the shooting in Nashville
uh here's Karin Jean-Pierre White House
Press Secretary responding to uh to the
event in his State of the Union the
president called on Congress to do
something
to stop the epidemic of gun violence
tearing families apart tearing
communities apart
how many more children have have to be
murdered
before republicans in Congress will step
up and act to pass the assault weapons
ban
I don't mean to be flip on a topic like
this but I have to roll my eyes when I
listen to her she immediately this is
about the guns good people with guns do
not shoot people and a good guy with a
gun did save the day here
um this is just 101 with these guys
right oh look it it's even worse than
that
um
all Democrats care about with these kind
of mass murders is politics
what happened in Nashville is horrific
three nine-year-olds
are dead three adults are dead it was a
sick and twisted Act of mass murder
what could have stopped it the number
one thing that could have stopped it is
if there had been an armed police
officer at the school
when the killer arrived
now last year I introduced legislation
that would double the number of police
officers in schools
15 billion dollars funding for police
officers and schools to double the
number of police officers in schools and
it wasn't just Public Schools it was
also private schools parochial schools
the number one way to keep our kids safe
is having armed police officers at the
door we know this shooter fired through
the door shattered the door with the gun
if there'd been a police officer there
the shooter could have been taken down
before a single child was killed
every single Democrat voted against my
bill to double the number of police
officers on campuses by the way the bill
also provided funding to enhance school
security to put in things like
bulletproof doors which she couldn't
have shot through but that uh the
Democrats blocked and I'll tell you I
stood on the senate floor
and I tried to pass my bill
on the senate floor and Chris Murphy the
leading advocate of gun control I stood
up and presented an argument this Bill
had funding for doubling police officers
funding for School Safety and Security
funding for mental health counselors so
many of the people who commit these mass
murders are twisted young men who have
serious mental health issues
I gave an entire speech laying out the
reasons we should support it
Chris Murphy stood up he said two words
he said I object
he didn't even bother to argue against
that he presented no arguments because
here's the Democrats view they don't
want to stop these crimes
if you want to stop these crimes you'd
put cops there to stop these crimes what
they want to do is they want to disarm
you they look at this and say hey it's
an excuse to take Dave rubin's guns they
all they care about look they're
fundraising
the left cares about gun control they
care about disarming law-abiding
citizens and part of the reason the
Democrats can be so contemptuous
to the best of my knowledge not a single
Democrat Senator has been asked once by
one reporter hey why did you vote
against doubling the number of police
officers on campus they know that the
the corporate press is going to lie for
them Kareem Jean-Pierre can stand up
there and say it's the mean old
Republicans and you know what no one
asked
well why did the Democrat block why did
the Democrats in the Senate block
funding to double the number of cops on
campus and stop this shooter and and I'm
sure you've seen the body cam footage
it's incredible the work that these guys
did they all just the Courage the
heroism they're going in they're hearing
the shots fired and they don't run away
from the shots they run towards the
shots and and they take out the killer
that saved a lot of lives that day but
if those officers had been there on the
front end they could have taken out the
killer before even a single child was
killed what do you make of the fact that
I suppose it's connected to what you're
saying the end goal of taking the guns
that Democrats and the media refused to
discuss anything related to mental
health I'm sure you remember this clip I
think the day after the Uvalde shooting
Joy Reid went on air and said this
person was not mentally ill this is
about guns and it's like by definition
if you can do something that evil you
you you are mentally a sane mentally
healthy person would not do that but but
there's a complete refusal to discuss
that where I know Republicans will at
least discuss guns they may not you know
gun rights and and that sort of thing
they may not come to the same
conclusions but they won't even discuss
it and especially in this case where the
person may will find out you know might
be there might be testosterone involved
and all of the other medications Etc
look this person and we'll find out the
story behind them but they were clearly
deranged
by definition
anyone that comes into a school and
murders a bunch of kids
it's crazy out of their mind they are
crazy and they are evil that there's and
and look in Texas I'm I have been at too
many of these mass shootings
I've been there in Santa Fe Santa Fe
High School is about 45 minutes away
from my house I was home that morning of
the shooting
I drove down there I was there within
about an hour of the shooting
I saw the horrors there I was there in
Sutherland Springs the worst church
shooting in history
I was there the day after it happened I
stood in that Sanctuary that beautiful
sanctuary small Church covered in blood
still glass shattered everywhere cell
phones shattered covered in blood that
monster
stood there executing people he shot an
18 month old baby
and by the way he was taken out
by Stephen Williford a plumber who lived
down the road who grabbed his AR-15 ran
down and shot him and saved the lives of
the rest of the people in that church
you know there's a real similarity
between the two topics we've discussed
between immigration and and gun control
on both of those
Democrats never ever ever want to
discuss the lives they are destroying
they don't want to talk about the kids
who are being sexually assaulted or
being raped who are being killed they
don't want to talk about the the human
trafficking they don't want to talk
about the murders they don't want to
talk about the crimes they don't want to
talk about the gang members the
suffering they don't care about all that
matters is their political objective of
open borders because open borders means
they believe more Democrat voters so all
the rest of it doesn't matter same is
true and gun control
Democrats don't want to talk about how
do we stop crime listen I've spent 11
years in the Senate fighting to stop
these kind of crimes and the way you
stop crime is you go after the criminals
you lock them up and for over a decade
the Democrats have passed bill after
Bill after Bill that I've introduced
that goes after gun criminals that locks
them up that puts them in jail that gets
them off the street the Democrats don't
want to do that what they want to do is
disarm as look Dianne Feinstein said if
I could say to Mr America Mrs America
give me your gun I'd do it that's what
they want
just on a personal note then I want to
jump over to we could obviously do a ton
on this but I want to talk about the the
tick tock situation on a personal note
you know having spent time in the
Capitol yesterday
you're walking around the hallway with
these guys you're probably having lunch
at the commissary sitting next to some
of these people it wasn't always like
this
do you see any way of of turning that
back a bit
so yes and I will say so some good news
in the Senate we actually get along
pretty well
um the house not so much my sense is the
house they really hate each other and
they're nasty to each other I mean it's
it's genuinely unpleasant at some point
if you keep calling someone a fascist
they they start taking it personally you
know the Senate has a different number
one the Senate's older I think the
median age is about 106. so you know
that when you're in a walker it's hard
to be that threat you're a young buck
over there that they they think I'm in
short shorts and like you know wearing a
beanie um
it's also the case the Senate you have
six-year terms
um everyone in the Senate understands
I'm going to be working with these
people for a long time there are only
100 of us
and the person you're fighting today
tomorrow you may need to work with on a
different matter
and so that dynamic in the Senate we
battle like crazy but there are actually
a bunch of Democrats I get along really
well with I'm you know I'm friends with
with Cory Booker I'm friends with
Kirsten gillibrand I'm friends with Amy
Klobuchar actually interestingly enough
the three of them in the 2020 Democrat
presidential uh primary all three of
them ran and all three use the same joke
on the trail they said
heck I even work with Ted Cruz not even
Ted Cruz and it look that is a laugh
line if you want to run for president as
a Democrat that consistently got laugh
lines Raphael Warnock the very liberal
Democrat from Georgia he ran millions of
dollars of TV ads in Georgia in his
re-elect talking about a bill that I
authored the Cruz Warnock bill
to build i-14 and interstate highway
from the Permian Basin in Texas all the
way across Southeast U.S through to
Georgia through to the Atlantic and I
mean he leaned in hard of look Cruz and
I worked together we got this done
that does help in the Senate that you
could battle
really hard
but you try not to make it personal you
try to have the substance be the area of
disagreement rather than personal
attacks is uh and then what we want is
the possible solution to that instead of
these two-year terms where you're just
endlessly running that you maybe make
them let's say four-year but then you're
capped at two two terms and then you
gotta go something like that look I
think that would help and I'm I'm a big
believer in term limits I I am the
author of a term limits Constitutional
Amendment that would cap house members
at three terms Senate members at two
terms I think term limits would be a
game changer
more than two-thirds of the American
people support term limits it's upwards
of 80 percent what's amazing is that
it's more than two-thirds of Republicans
more than two-thirds of Independents
more than two-thirds of Democrats
support term limits the one group that
does it is career politicians in
Washington all of the Democrats oppose
it I've been trying to get even one
Democrat Senator all the Democrats
running for president in 2020 I was like
look couldn't one of you break from the
herd and say you're from for term limits
your voters all support them
but Democrats are collectivists
they are comfortable with centralized
power they follow orders I have
conversations all the time where I tell
Democrats it's not that hard
to stand up to your leadership I tell
Democrats I can't do this Schumer
wouldn't let me and I start laughing I'm
like okay I don't ask Mitch McConnell
before I do things and the idea that he
thinks he could tell me
he wouldn't even try because he knows it
wouldn't work
um
look I think term limits would make a
big difference I also think
we're at a really fraught time in
politics you know I've talked about this
before where we're so polarized we're so
tribalized
I don't like
that we don't talk to each other anymore
that the left listens to left-wing news
the right listens to right wing news and
you demonize and attack anyone who
disagrees and if someone disagrees you
unfriend them you block them on social
media so everyone's in their their own
Echo chamber
it's a terrible situation look it's one
of the things you you do with your
podcast it's one of the things I try to
do with my podcast I try to talk to
people you know we've taken our pieces
the key word because it's getting harder
it is but let me give you let me give
you a moment of encouragement so we've
taken the podcast verdict on the road we
do campus tours and we've gone to a
bunch of left-wing campuses we were at
Yale University
which six seven hundred people come out
to see the podcast live
and I'd say about a third of the people
who came were left or Center I know this
because it was right after catanji Brown
Jackson was confirmed and I mentioned it
about 200 people began applauding
and I said to them I said hey thank you
I am really really glad you're here
because we're not going to make it as a
country if we can't talk to each other
and if we can't have a real conversation
there were several transgender students
there who I didn't know if they'd stand
up and scream and have a protest and
they didn't and we had it's almost all q
a and we have a policy which you'll
appreciate which is if you have a
hostile question if you have an
antagonistic question come to the front
yep
and look occasionally we had it at
University of Wisconsin-Madison we had
one leftist who like stood up and said
Fu and you know he had this frizon of
power that he ran out the back door and
I said well thank you for bringing a
civil discourse to this conversation
like like you just yeah but what was
interesting
we spent 90 minutes at Yale afterwards I
had drinks with with an orthodox Rabbi
on campus
and he told me he said Ted that was the
single largest group of students that I
have seen have a civil constructive
meaningful conversation on conservative
ideas he said in 20 years he said this
doesn't happen at Yale I think there's a
hunger out there for it and I think what
you're doing is important I think
we've got to learn to talk to each other
with a smile not being jackasses
but actually talking about substance and
I think people want that well that now
I'm going to ask you a favor while we're
live which is that we came down here we
requested interviews from about 20
Republicans basically every single
person said yes the only person who
couldn't do it was Mitch McConnell he's
obviously got a he fell so okay fine
yeah no he had been not at work in the
last couple of weeks not one Democrat
said yes so I'm going to ask you to
connect us with Cory Booker and who'd
you say kobachar and the other one and
let's see let's see and I would treat
them exactly as I treat you even though
they would know I disagree so but but
they're not going to say yes and and the
bizarre thing is look you look at at
sexual orientation politics
as far as the Democrats are concerned
you're not gay
I'm not Hispanic Clarence Thomas is not
black I'm only gay starting at 10 pm
usually
well look I mean the bizarre thing is
their definition
they claim to care about all these
categories of people yeah but they don't
actually
they care only as long as you obey
their Orthodoxy you obey their Dogma you
you stand up and say if you dare
disagree and the irony is they get much
more angry
at what they view uppity minorities yeah
for me to DARE Jorge Ramos on air called
me a traitor to my race yeah we covered
it we covered it you know they get you
look at the contempt that is visited on
Clarence Thomas
contrast it to Anton and Scalia now
incidentally I knew Justice Scalia well
he was brilliant he was incredibly
conservative
look they didn't like Scalia but they
didn't loathe him Thomas I mean you saw
magazine covers painting it as an Uncle
Tom licking scalia's shoes they loathe
him because he's a traitor he's not
supposed to DARE disagree and if you're
gay you're supposed to be a leftist
socialist authoritarian and if you're
not they get very angry
it really is as simple as that it's kind
of unfortunate Center I know you got a
crazy day I appreciate you swinging by
we'll do this again whether whether I
can get a Klobuchar to sit down I'm not
saying I think I can get Cruise again
absolutely good seeing you my friend
thank you man take care
foreign